I can't watch any of my old stuff
because it's all I see
he goes you'll watch his background
actor there's one that they asked me if
I wanted to go fix it and there's people
playing tennis because there was no box
it wasn't making too much noise and you
couldn't see the ball because the way
the fence and whatever was but they got
into this Rhythm that they weren't
taking turns doing Strokes so they're on
opposite sides of the thing both at the
same time and I'm like what are they
playing it makes me insane I'll send it
this is life it's the worst have you
seen the broom that isn't touching the
ground it's a classic oh my god dude
there's a guy and he's got a huge push
from it
I used to collect that I got
there's a I got one there's a pizza
delivery person that uh right before
they they come they they in the pizza
that they're holding it like this at
first
like a book
by the way uh
[Music]